[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN WICKE: I'm Martin Wicke.
I'm the engineer lead
for a TensorFlow 2,
and I am going to,
unsurprisingly, talk
about TensorFlow 2.
TensorFlow has been
extremely successful.
And inside of Google,
outside of Google,
it has grown into
a vibrant community
that really when we started it
we were not able to imagine.
And our users are building
these ingenious, clever, elegant
things everyday
from art and music,
from what you just heard about
medieval manuscripts, science,
and medicine.
And the things people created
were unexpected and beautiful.
And we learned a lot from that.
And we learned a lot
from how people did it.
And TensorFlow flow has
enabled all this creativity
and really jumpstarted this
whole AI democratization,
which is great.
But it has been a little
bit hard to use sometimes
And we know.
At sometimes it's
been a little painful.
So using sessions wasn't
the most natural thing
to do when coming
from regular Python.
And the TensorFlow API
has grown over time
and got a little bit cluttered,
a little bit confusing.
In the end, you can do
everything with TensorFlow,
but it wasn't always
clear what's the best
way to do it with TensorFlow.
And so we've learned a
lot since we started this,
and we realized that you
need rapid prototyping,
you need easier debugging,
there's a lot of clutter.
So we're fixing this.
We're addressing these
issues with a new version
of TensorFlow--
today, releasing an
alpha of TensorFlow 2.
Many of you have participated
in the design reviews
that went into this
for all the features
that we have implemented.
Those of you who
are really living
on the bleeding
edge of development
have probably played
with a nightly.
You have installed it.
You have tested it.
You have found issues.
You have fixed issues.
So thank you very
much for your help.
You can now install the
alpha release of TensorFlow 2
using just pip install
--pre tenserflow.
And you can go and play with it.
So what has changed?
When we create TensorFlow
2, really the biggest focus
is on usability.
We've adopted Keras as the
high level API for TensorFlow.
We've integrated it very
deeply with TensorFlow.
Keras gives you a clear path
of how to develop models,
how to deployment models.
It has a [INAUDIBLE] API
that makes people productive,
and we know that it gets
you started quickly.
TensorFlow also includes
a complete implementation
of Keras, of course.
But we went further.
We have extended
Keras so that you
can use all of the advanced
features in TensorFlow
directly from tf.keras.
The other big change
in TensorFlow 2
is that it is Eager execution
by default. Traditional 1.x
TensorFlow used a
declarative style,
and it was often a little bit
dissonant with the surrounding
Python.
And in TensorFlow 2,
TensorFlow behaves just
like the surrounding code.
So if you add up
two numbers, you
get a result back immediately,
which is amazing, really.
[LAUGHTER]
But you still get
all the benefits
of working with A graph--
robust program serializating,
easy distribution
of programs,
distributed computation,
optimizations on the graph.
All of that stuff is not going
away, it's just getting easier.
So TensorFlow 2 is
a major release,
which means that we have
the ability to clean it up.
And we did-- like, a lot.
So we had a lot of
duplicate functionality
that we have removed.
We've consolidated the API.
We've organized the API.
We've made sure that the API
looks and feels consistent.
And this is not only
about TensorFlow itself,
this is about the whole
ecosystem of tools that
has grown around TensorFlow.
We've spent a lot of
effort to try and align
all of these interfaces.
And we've defined
exchange formats
that'll allow you to move
all throughout this ecosystem
without hitting any barriers.
We have removed a lot of
stuff from TensorFlow,
but that doesn't
mean that it's not--
it has gotten more
flexible, not less.
It retains and expands
on the flexibility
we had that enabled all
of this development.
And we've created a
more complete low level
API that now exposes all
of the internally use ops
to the users via
the robs module.
We provide
inheritable interfaces
for all of the crucial
concepts in TensorFlow,
like variables and checkpoints.
And this allows
framework authors
to build on top of
TensorFlow while maintaining
interoperability with the
rest of the ecosystem.
And you'll hear a lot
of these examples later.
There'll be talk about
TF agents later today.
There'll be a talk about
Sonnet by DeepMind tomorrow.
So you'll see examples of
how this works in practice.
Now, the real question for
you is, of course, what
do I have to do to be a
part of this great new era
of TensorFlow?
And we know it's always
hard to upgrade to anything.
And that's especially true
for major version upgrades.
At Google, we will
now start the process
of converting one of the
largest codebases in the world
to TensorFlow 2.
And while we're
doing that, we'll
be writing a lot of
migration guides.
we have started that
already, and some of them
are online and will provide a
lot of best practices for you.
And if we can do it at Google,
you can probably do it too.
So we're giving you
and us a lot of tools
to make this transition easier.
And first of all, as
part of TensorFlow 2,
we're shipping a
compatibility module--
we call it tf.compat.v1--
which contains all
of the 1.x API.
So if you rely on a specific
deprecated function,
you can still use it, and
you can still find it there,
except for t
tf.contrib, which is not
going to be included at all.
But we've created a
community-supported alternative
that support your use case if
you rely on something in there.
We're also publishing a script
which will automatically
update your code so it
runs on TensorFlow 2.
Let me show you how that works.
Let's say I want to
convert this program, which
is a simple example that we
have online of a simple language
model trained on Shakespeare.
So what I do is I simply
run tf_upgrade_v2,
which is a utility that's
included with any installation
of TensorFlow 2.
It tells me what it did.
And in this case, there's
really just a handful of things
that it changed.
And you can see, if you
look at what changed,
there's some functions
that it renamed.
The reorganization of the API
leads to renamed functions.
So multinomial was actually the
wrong name for this function.
So it renamed it to
random.categorical.
That's something the
script will do for you,
so you don't have to
worry too much about it.
A lot of functions had arguments
renamed, their order changed,
or some arguments
added or deleted.
As far as possible, the
script will make those changes
for you.
And then, if all else
fails, sometimes there
isn't really a perfect
equivalent in TensorFlow 2
to a symbol that
existed in TensorFlow 1
And then, we'll use the
compatibility module
that I talked about earlier.
If there is no
perfect replacement,
we'll use that in
order to make sure
that your code still works as
expected after the conversion.
So it's pretty conservative.
So for instance,
the AdamOptimizer
is a very subtle behavior
change that mostly probably
won't affect you.
But just in case it
might, we will convert it
to compat.v1 AdamOptimizer.
Once the conversion is complete
and there were no errors,
then you can run the new
program in TensorFlow 2,
and it'll work.
That's the idea.
So it should be
pretty easy for you.
Hopefully, you
won't get trouble.
Note that this
automatic conversion,
it will fix it so it works,
but it won't fix your style
to the new TensorFlow 2 style.
That cannot be
done automatically.
And there's a lot to
learn about this process,
so if you want to know more,
check out the talk by Anna
and Tomer tomorrow
at 10:30 about 2.0
and porting your models.
That'll be worthwhile.
Of course, as we go through
this process at Google,
we'll also publish a
lot more documentation.
But this talk is the best start.
All right.
So let me give you an idea about
the timeline of all of this.
We have cut 2.0 alpha
today or yesterday--
it took some time building it.
We're now working on
implementing some missing
features that we
already know about.
We're converting libraries.
We're converting Google.
There's lots of testing,
lots of optimization
that's going to happen over
the next couple of months.
We're targeting to have a
release candidate in spring.
Spring is a sort of
flexible concept--
[LAUGHTER]
But in spring.
After we have this
release candidate,
it still has to go through
release testing and integration
testing, so I expect that to
take a little bit longer than a
for our regular release chains.
But that's when you can
see an RC, and then,
eventually, a final.
So if you want to follow along
with the process, please do so.
All of this is tracked online.
It's all on the GitHub
TensorFlow 2 project tracker.
So I would just go
and look at that
to stay up to date
if you were looking
for a particular feature or just
want to know what's going on.
If you file any bugs, those end
up there as well so everybody
knows what's going on.
So TensorFlow 2 really wouldn't
be possible without you.
That has been the case already.
But in the future, even more
so, we'll need you to test this.
We'll need you to tell us
what works and what doesn't.
So please install
the alpha today.
We're extremely excited to see
what you can create with us.
So please go, install the
alpha, check out the docs.
They're at tensorflow.org/r2.0.
And with that, I think
you should probably
hear about what it's like to
be working with TensorFlow 2.
We'll have plenty of content
over the next couple of days
to tell you exactly about all
the different aspects of it.
But we'll start with Karmel,
who will speak about high level
APIs in TensorFlow 2.0.
Thank you
[APPLAUSE]
KARMEL ALLISON: Hi.
My name is Karmel Allison,
and I'm an engineering manager
for TensorFlow.
Martin just told you
about TensorFlow 2.0
and how to get
there. and I'm going
to tell you a little bit
about what we're bringing
in our high level
API and what you can
expect to find when you arrive.
But first, what do I mean
when I say high level APIs?
There are many common
pieces and routines
in building machine
learning models, just
like building houses.
And with our high level
APIs, we bring your tools
to help you more easily and
reproducibly build your models
and scale them.
As Martin mentioned,
a couple of years
ago, TensorFlow adopted Keras
as one of the high level
APIs we offered.
Keras is, at its
heart, a specification
for model building.
It works with multiple
machine learning frameworks,
and it provides
a shared language
for defining layers, models,
losses, optimizers, and so on.
We implemented a
version of Keras
that has been optimized
for TensorFlow
inside of core
TensorFlow, and we
called it TF Keras, one
of our high level APIs.
Raise your hand if you
used TF Keras already?
OK, a lot of you.
That's good, because this
next slide will seem familiar.
In its simplest form,
Keras is just that, simple.
It was built from
the ground up to be
Pythonic and easy to learn.
And as such, it has been
instrumental in inviting people
in to the machine
learning world.
The code here represents
an entire model definition
and training loop, meaning
it's really easy for you
to design and modify your model
architectures without needing
to write tons of boilerplate.
At the same time, by relying
on inheritance and interfaces,
Keras is extremely
flexible and customizable,
which is critical for machine
learning applications.
Here we have a subclass model.
I can define arbitrary
model architectures,
modify what happens
at each training step,
and even change the whole
training loop if I want to.
Which is to say, Keras
is simple and effective.
Anyone can figure
out how to use it.
But we had a problem, TF Keras
was built for smaller models.
And many machine
learning problems,
including the ones we
see internally at Google,
need to operate at
a much larger scale.
And so we have estimators.
Estimators were built from
the ground up to distribution
and scale with fault tolerance
across hundreds of machines,
no questions asked.
This here is the much-loved
wide and deep model,
a workhorse of the
machine learning
world that took many years
of research to define
but is available as a built-in
for training and deployment.
Which is to say, estimators
are powerful machines.
But you've told us that
there's a steep learning curve,
and it's not always
easy to figure out
which parts to connect where.
And we learned a lot
in the past two years
building out
estimator in TF Keras
And we've reached
the point that we
don't think you
should have to choose
between a simple API
and a scalable API.
We want a higher
level API that takes
you all the way from
[INAUDIBLE] to planet scale,
no questions asked.
So in TensorFlow 2.0, we are
standardizing on the Keras API
for building layers and models.
but we are bringing all
the power of estimators
into TF Keras, so that you
can move from prototype
to distributed training to
production serving in one go.
OK, so brass tacks--
how are we doing this?
Well, this is a TF Keras model
definition in TensorFlow 1.13.
And this is the same
model definition in 2.0.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of you may notice the
code is exactly the same.
OK, so what actually
is different?
Well, we've done a lot of
work to integrate Keras
with all of the other features
that TensorFlow 2.0 brings
to the table.
For example, in 1.13 this
built a graph-based model that
ran a session under the hood.
In 2.0, the same
model definition
will run in Eager mode
without any modification.
This lets you take advantage of
everything Eager can do for us.
Here we see that our data
set pipeline behaves just
like a numpy array,
easy to debug
and flows natively
into our Keras model.
But at the same
time, data sets have
been optimized for
performance so that you
can iterate over and
train with a data set
with minimal
performance overhead.
We're able to achieve
this performance
with data sets in Keras by
taking advantage of graphs,
even in an Eager context.
Eager makes debugging
and prototyping easy,
and all the while Keras builds
an Eager-friendly function,
under the hood, that
tracks your model,
and the TensorFlow
runtime then takes
care of optimizing for
performance and scaling.
That said, you can
also explicitly run
your model step-by-step in Eager
mode with the flag run_eagerly.
Even though for this example,
it might be overkill,
you can see that
run_eagerly allows
you to use Python control flow
and Eager mode for debugging
while you're
prototyping your model.
Another big change
coming in 2.0 is
that we have consolidated
many APIs across TensorFlow
under the Keras heading,
reducing duplicative classes
and making it easier to know
what you should use and when.
We now have one
set of optimizers.
These optimizers work
across TensorFlow
in and out of eager mode, on
one machine or distributed.
You can retrieve and
set hyperparamters
like normal Python attributes,
and these optimizers
fully serializable.
The weights and
configuration can
be saved both in the
TensorFlow checkpoint
format and the backend
diagnostic Keras format.
We have one set of metrics that
encompasses all the former TF
metrics and Keras metrics and
allow for easy subclassing
if you want even more.
Losses, similarly, have been
consolidated into a single set
with a number of frequently
used built-ins and an easily
customizable interface
if you so choose.
And we have one set
of layers, built
in the style of Keras layers.
Which means that
they are class-based
and fully configurable.
There are a great number of
built in layers, including
all of the ones that come with
the Keras API specification.
One set of layers that we took
particular care with where
the RNN layers in TensorFlow.
Raise your hand if you've
used RNN layers in TensorFlow?
OK, these slides are for you.
[LAUGHTER]
In TensorFlow V1 we had
several different versions
of LSTm and GRUs, and
you had to know ahead
of time what device you
were optimizing for in order
to get peak performance
with cuDNN kernels.
In 2.0, there is one
version of the LSTM
and one version
of the GRU layer.
And they select
the write operation
for the available
device at runtime
so that you don't have to.
This code here runs
the cuDNN kernel
if you have GPUs
available, but also
falls back to CPU ops if you
don't have GPUs available.
In addition to all
of those, if you
need layers that are not
included in the built-in set,
TF Keras provides an API that is
easy to subclass and customize
so that you can innovate on
top of the existing layers.
This, in fact, is how
the community repository
TensorFlow add-ons operates.
They provide specialized and
particularly complex layers--
metrics, optimizers, and so on--
to the TensorFlow
community by building
on top of the
Keras base classes.
All right.
So we streamlined API--
that's a start.
The next thing we did
was integrate Keras
across all of the
tools and capabilities
that TensorFlow has.
One of the tools we found
critical to the development
of estimators was easily
configurable structured data
passing with feature columns.
In TensorFlow 2.0 you
can use feature columns
to parse your data
and feed it directly
into downstream Keras layers.
These feature columns work
both with Keras and estimators,
so you can mix and match to
create reusable data input
pipelines.
OK.
So you have data in your model,
and you're ready to train.
One of the most loved tools we
have for running your training
jobs is TensorBoard.
And I'm pleased to
say in TensorFlow 2.0,
TensorBoard integration with
Keras is as simple as one line.
Here we add a TensorBoard
callback to our model
when training.
And this gets us both
our training progress--
here we see accuracy and loss--
and a conceptual graph
representing the model we
built layer-by-layer.
As an added bonus,
this same callback even
includes full profiling
of your model,
so you can better understand
your model's performance
and device placement, and
you can more readily find
ways to minimize bottlenecks.
Speaking of performance,
one of the exciting pieces
we're bringing to
TensorFlow 2.0 is
the tf.distribute.Strategy API.
In TensorFlow 2.0
we will have a set
of built in strategies for
distributing your training
workflows that work
natively with Keras.
These APIs have been
designed to be easy to use,
to have great
out-of-the-box performance,
and to be versatile enough
to handle many different
distribution
architectures and devices.
So how do they work?
Well, with Keras you can add and
switch distribution strategies
with only a few lines of code.
Here we are distributing
the same model you just
saw across multiple GPUs by
defining the model network,
compiling, and fitting within
the distribution strategy
scope.
Because we've integrated
distribution strategies
throughout Keras in
TensorFlow, you get a lot
with these few lines of code.
Data will be prefetched
to GPUs batch-by-batch,
variables will be
mirrored in sync
across all available
devices using allreduce,
and we see greater than
90% over multiple GPUs.
This means you can scale your
model up without changing code
and without losing any of
the conveniences of Keras.
Once you've trained
your model, you're
likely going to want to package
it for use with production
systems, mobile phones, or
other programming languages,
Keras models can
now export directly
to saved_model,
the serialization
format that works across
the TensorFlow ecosystem.
This functionality
is experimental
while we iron out a few
API details, but today,
and going into
2.0, you can easily
export your models for use with
TF Serving, TF Lite, and more.
You can also easily
reload these models back
into Python to continue
training and using
in your normal workflow.
So that's where we are
today in the alpha.
But we're obviously
not done yet,
so let me tell you a little
bit about what's coming up
in the next few months.
We talked about
distributing over multi-GPU,
but that's just the start.
Using the same model code,
we can swap out our strategy
and scale up to multiple nodes.
Here we take the
same Keras model
we just saw and distribute
it across multiple machines,
all working in sync
using collective ops
to train your model
faster than ever before.
Multi-worker mirrored strategy
currently supports ring
and nickel for allreduce, which
allows us to achieve great
out-of-the-box performance.
This API is still
being developed,
but you can try it out
today in the nightlies
if you are interested in a
TensorFlow-native solution
to synchronous multi
worker training.
And we are very excited
to say that using Keras
and distribute
strategies you will also
be able to use the same code to
distribute your model on TPUs.
You'll have to wait for the
next TensorFlow release for this
to actually work on TPUs.
But when it's
released, this strategy
will still work on
Google Cloud TPUs
and with Colab, which can
now access TPUs directly.
And as we approach
the final 2.0 release,
we will continue bringing
scalability into Keras.
We will be enabling distribution
with parameter service
strategy, which is the
multi-node asynchronous
training that
estimator does today.
We will also be exposing canned
estimator like wide and deep
directly from the Keras
API for those of you
who want a higher
level higher level API.
And we will be adding support
for partitioned variables
across many machines for some
of the largest scale models,
like those we run at Google.
And that's just a sneak peak.
So please do check
out the 2.0 preview
and try out TF Keras
if you haven't already.
If you have more
questions, you'll
be hearing more throughout the
day about Keras and high level
API and how they integrate
across TensorFlow.
And we also have a workshop
tomorrow that Martin mentioned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]